oh yeah this movie has the creepiest
thing known to man in the mythos
creepier than the Incubus the succubus
the heck abyss or the Jack abyss this
movie has starred on Don creepy old
people
the visit so the visits written and
directed by M night Shyamalan and what
looks like an attempt to tell We the
People hey I still want to make good
movies that I can still do that right
let is up to you mr. Shyamalan so the
visits ultimately I found footage film
they achieved that because the girl in
this movie was she's an aspiring
filmmaker since she wants to do a
documentary on her grandparents so in
that the found-footage aspect in this
movie does make more sense and a lot of
other found footage movies out there
were similar hey I'm just filming this
just because these two kids these two
child actors that's right I'm not
Shyamalan in an attempt to show us that
he can still have people with good
acting in his movies chooses child
actors that is ballsy and it's a gamble
but it does pay off because the two kids
are really good in this movie the little
brother was good comedy relief in this
movie sometimes there were tonal
conflicts between comedy and what should
be horror and we'll get more into that a
little later but the point is they were
good he was good she was good there are
a couple of moments where it's like this
movie starts pulling heartstrings and
this girl has to pull off a power scene
where you're like hey good luck but she
does it and that really impresses me
know it's safe to say if you saw the
trailer you know these grandparents are
just creepy ass people you don't really
know why but they're just you don't want
to be there and neither do those kids
because when the Sun Goes Down that
grandma she starts going a little
bananas and there were a couple scenes
roles like oh this is kind of raising
the hair in the back of my neck
couple of jump-scares happen in this
movie roles like you're not gonna do
jump scares the entire time aria but
among scenes that did work there were a
couple scenes that could have been real
power hitting creepy ass scenes and then
the kid will say something that's funny
it just breaks the tension right there I
just think the value would have been
greater if the kid just didn't say
anything at that particular moment maybe
he could have said something the next
morning sorry there is one scene when
is going down it's so funny in a
dick way I laughed I lost it and
everything after that wasn't as creepy
as it should have been because I was
still laughing about that one thing I'm
still laughing about it the answer for
that is simple because I'm a dick but it
was funny and there were a couple scenes
in this movie I was like I think I'm
supposed to be creeped out right here
I'm not really like when the kids are
playing hide and go seek kind of the
houses or whatever oh this is supposed
to it's not really landing today and
there are definitely scenes in this
movie where you're like this movie's
kind of dragging on is it going to have
a point because it's not been
particularly scary I'm enjoying the kids
I'm enjoying the movie enough but it's
not as creepy as I want it to be but by
the end
respectively you look back and you're
like yeah I actually did enjoy that
movie it looks like when the aliens took
Shyamalan the good director and replaced
him with the weird alien hybrid robot
that made shitty movies from then on
they have returned Shyamalan is like all
right well looks like you got to build
everything from the ground up so I'm
gonna do found-footage which is a smart
move dare I say almost genius move on
Shyamalan sparked I mean the movie cost
is a ham sandwich budget to make it so
even if it makes a little bit of money
at Lake its money back just looks like
this is a movie that Shyamalan did as a
passion project and doing a movie
because you want to do a movie is the
best reason for a filmmaker to make a
movie guys in the end the visit starts
out as a slow grind for the long haul
but the kid actors were good in the
movie the grandparents were creepy in
the movie the movie effectively does
what it sets out to do for the most part
and by the end there was some tonal
conflicts in there sometimes the movie
was a little funnier than it should have
been if it wanted to be a creepy movie
at that moment but in the end I will say
the visit is a good time no alcohol
required
I feel like Shyamalan should stay in
this pocket do the personal stories do
the really claustrophobic creepy movies
a big-budget action movies if this not
you man do this doesn't always have to
be found footage but you know smaller is
better right so the visit have you seen
it what did you think about it what is
your favorite M night Shyamalan movie so
far whatever you think whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more